قطعت حرب اوكرانيا الوصل الروسيه الاوروبي
والروسيه الامريكيه في مجال الفضاء لكنها
قربت المسافه اكثر مع الصين منافسي امريكا
الاول في برنامج اعاده البشر الى القمر
اذ كلف الصراع وكاله الفضاء الروسيه
روسكوزموس شاركتها مع نظيرتها الاوروبيه
ففي ابريل علقت تعاونه في عده بعثات قمريه
ومشروع نوعي لارسال مركبه فضائيه الى
المريخ
خساره تكبدتها روسيا بعد تعليق شركه
الاقمار الصناعيه وانلمتد ومقرها لندن في
مارس الماضي جميع عمليات الاطلاق من منصات
اطلاق روسيه عزله روسيه وجدت فيها بكين
فرصه شراكه مهمه لمقاومه ضغوط امريكا في
فرض قواعد الاقتصاد الفضاء الناشئ لكن
البرنامج الروسي ليس في افضل احواله فبحسب
صحيفه
تراجع انتاج الفضاء الروسي الى الثلث في
اقل من عام رغم ذلك ترى الصحيفه ان تعاون
يظل ضروريا على مستوى تطوير اجهزه استشعار
فضائيه للكشف عن صواريخ بالستيا وصواريخ
فرط صوتيه
شراكه قد تفتح شهيه شركاء اخرين للانضمام
لسباق الغزو الفضائي بين الولايات المتحده
والصين التي لا تزال امريكا فيه المتصدر
الاول فامريكا تمتلك حصه الاسد من الاقمار
الصناعيه الناشطه التي تدور حول الارض
نتحدث عن نحو ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه قمر
صناعي امريكي الصين في المرتبه الثانيه
بعدد لا يتجاوز 600 قمر صناعي وروسيا التي
تحاول اللحاق بالركب ب 172 قمرا صناعيا
حتى الان لا توجد اليه دوليه تعالج
الجرائم او المخالفات الفرديه خارج الكوكب
لذا فان شرطي الفضاء القادم من يسن
القواعد ويضع المعايير قد يكون هو نفسه
شرطي العالم الجديد في وقت قريب جدا كرمح
النووي العربيه